jimmy saké à de nice black metal il
n'existe rien de constant si ce n'est le
changement bouddha en 2017
durant l'ascension du strip ada au sri
lanka au lieu de pèlerinage pour nos
quatre religions majeur j'ai tenté de
comprendre ce besoin de changement dans
la religion vous déguiser en effet que
dans sa vie on peut atteindre à un
moment l'éveil le nirvana un état où
notre façon de voir les choses va
changer radicalement et si la religion
nous montre qu'il s'agit d'un objectif
depuis très longtemps le changement la
révolution technologique sans précédent
que nous connaissons nous montrent qu'il
s'agit d'un objectif immédiat et pour
tout le monde
accélérez augmenté améliorer transformer
ou modifier changé la rupture est
partout alors à la coupe de ce navire
qui le progrès on trouve souvent le
transhumanisme accompagné de ses fidèles
compagnons que sont l'intelligence
artificielle la robotisation de corps
humain ou encore les mortalités j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser au transvaal
nisme car j'étais passionné de nouvelles
technologies et cette envie de changer
un peu le monde à ma manière
mais aujourd'hui devant vous c'est
différent il est temps de rentrer dans
le dur c'est bien beau d'explorer le
futur mais il est temps de mettre les
mains dans le cambouis plutôt kabylité
de se les salaires alors qu'est ce que
le transhumanisme déjà par définition
améliorer l'humain par le progrès
technique
alors ces vagues au sens large
on est tous déjà transmis aux vues par
exemple de ces prothèses que l'on a tous
dans nos poches
les téléphones sont des prothèses de
mémoire peut-être géolocalisation
prothèses de voix notamment et au sens
restreint de l'autre côté être
transhumanistes peut être vu comme être
un dieu fou souhaitant être immortel
cybernétique et délaissant
entre les deux il y as nous vous citoyen
qui ne savons pas forcément quel camp
choisir tous france humain où tous
contre alors ce soir
plutôt que de définir le transhumanisme
et c'est peut être bizarre sur un talk
sur le transhumanisme je vous promets de
ne pas le faire de ne pas se demander
s'il est bon ou mauvais mais deux avoir
une nouvelle base de se dire qu'il est
neutre et que c'est à nous de lui donner
la valeur qu'on souhaite
ça pourrait être game bien ça la
première valeur dans le transhumanisme
réapproprier s'écarter du débat qu'il ya
autour de son sens des quiproquos des
critiques qu'il ya autour
et même on pourra aller plus loin sans
et ça avec les technologies aussi
pourquoi être toujours le plus
technologique
le smartphone la montre connecter le
bras s'est connecté etc
je peux vous proposer ce soir un transit
manis mme où la technologie aurait du
sens mais elles seraient moins présente
prenez l'exemple par exemple des
personnes qui en implantant un
exosquelette parce qu'elles sont
paraplégiques
donc c'est quelque chose de très
encombrant très imposant et elles
trouvent souvent désagréable cette
robotisation al'inverse les personnes à
qui on implante des technologies
invisible comme la stimulation cérébrale
profonde dans le cas de la maladie de
parkinson dont qu'une seule peur c'est
que l'on arrête cette stimulation
bénéfique
autre exemple par exemple en 2018 on a
inventé un implant biodégradables qui
est capable de régénérer des nerfs après
une lésion et c'est un plan et des
gravats par le corps symbole d'une
technologie à fort potentiel mais qui se
faire totalement oubliée alors si on
veut que le progrès soit sociale il faut
lui donner du sens menu 100 parce que
nous faisons à comment nous avançons
plutôt que simplement avancé pour
avancer eh bien ça ça pourrait être le
deuxième fondement d'un transhumanistes
alternatif
donner du sens à nos technologies en
fait c'est même la réponse à ceux qui
l'accusent d' extrême dans le transit
man is seen on en suit les premiers
mouvements que l'on réduit souvent à la
silicon valley égoïstement au centre des
préoccupations il ya l'humain
c'est d'ailleurs ce que donne des
transhumanistes en hommage imposé à
l'humanisme des lumières l'humanisme de
la renaissance liste de vinci notamment
kim était déjà l'homme au centre des
préoccupations mais aujourd'hui penser
l'humain seulement avec toutes ces
technologies ce n'est au final n'être
qu'à tony stark iron man et non et si on
veut que le transit manis mais
aujourd'hui du sens il ne faut pas
qu'ils soient centrés que sur l'humain
mais sur toute l'humanité est encore
mieux plus puissants surtout
l'environnement
un traumatisme humains éthiques et
écologiques
alors avec l'écologie en ce moment ce
qui peut paraître marrant c'est qu'on
essaie de trouver des solutions humaines
pour améliorer nature mais on oublie
peut-être à quel point c'est la nature
qui peut nous apporter des solutions à
nos activités humaines par exemple il ya
cette idée des tanks bioluminescente qui
pourrait un jour éclairer nos villes ou
encore vous le connaissez sûrement plus
on s'inscrit aujourd'hui de nos réseaux
de neurones pour créer les réseaux de
neurones de l'intelligence artificielle
alors l'intelligence artificielle
l'encan ça sera projet à se rapprocher
pardon du centre de transit manie sme on
lui reproche souvent de placer beaucoup
d'espoir voire même tous les espoirs
dans la technologie dans l'avènement de
l'intelligence artificielle ou ia pour
résoudre tous nos problèmes mais ça ce
n'est pas le transhumanisme c'est le
techno prophétisme et c'est différent et
ça comporte même un problème majeur qui
font hésiter c'est celui du point
individuel de défaillance c'est lorsque
l' architecture d'un système passe un
moment par un unique point donné par
exemple c'est quand vous avez nous ici
chez vous et que si la wii qui ne
fonctionnent plus et ben alors tous les
appareils qui sont connectés la russie
ne vont plus fonctionner eh bien
imaginez maintenant qu'une intelligence
artificielle un algorithme
berne un pays voire le monde entier et
maintenant imaginez conséquences si
ainsi tout était déconnecté alors que
proposait que propose un traumatisme
alternatif à ça cela est bien ne plus
mettre l'intelligence artificielle comme
notre m mais comme notre meilleur outil
notre meilleure aide
c'est par exemple imaginer une ia
écologique écologique par mon verte
comme à google celle qui limite les
déperditions énergétiques des propre
datacenter qui l'héberge ou encore comme
j'ai eu la chance de la rencontrer
mail keane intelligence artificielle à
grenoble qui est capable de lire un irm
elle est capable de voir des petits avc
des petites rupture d'anévrisme plus
rapidement qu'un humain là où chaque
seconde compte
vous l'avez compris cette ia peut sauver
des vies l'a déjà fait à temps là où un
numéro un n'a pas pu le faire
une intelligence artificielle qui vous
sauve de la mort la mort là on est
vraiment au coeur des transhumanistes la
longévité
eh bien je pense ce soir qu'il est
possible d'inventer et de prôner un
étrange manie ce justement ne prennent
pas à l'immortalité comme on le sait
souvent comme on le voit souvent mais la
mortalité l'unss et ne plus jamais
mourir l'autre plus modestement c'est ne
pas savoir comme mourir ne pas avoir
d'espérance de vie limitée et peut-être
pouvoir la choisir en effet une
mortalité et c'est encore de la science
fiction et c'est même biologiquement
impossible à concevoir encore
aujourd'hui alors que au contraire il
faudrait bosser travailler pardon sur
les maladies en effet on souhaite tous
vivre vieux et on ne souhaite pas être
vue en ce sens il ne faut pas augmenter
l'espérance de vie tout court
mais l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
par exemple on sait que cela se confirme
aujourd'hui le vieillissement est une
maladie ou plutôt un ensemble de neuf
marqueurs comme la détérioration de
notre adn
qui augmente sensiblement la probabilité
d'avoir des maladies liées au
vieillissement alzheimer cataractes sont
par exemple 100% vieillesse c'est
l'agrégat désagrégation pardon de
protéines dans notre corps qui sont
toxiques et qui sont dues par des
cellules qui sont elles trop vieille et
si on agit sur ces maladies alors vivre
plus longtemps ne seraient que la
conséquence et non la cause première
ainsi je pense que un transit malice
modérée peut dire que nous pourrons
gagner au fur et à mesure jour après
jour mois après mois année après année
des années dit en plus mais ils héritent
il est irraisonnable de penser que du
jour au lendemain nous deviendrons tous
immortel alors le corps humain cette
belle machine le même temps on dit
souvent qu'elle a des limites
et d'ailleurs le transhumanisme à cette
tendance à dire que on pourrait dépasser
ses limites
aller plus loin malheureusement
aujourd'hui et ça c'est un avis
personnel ça passe trop souvent par la
robotisation l'oeil bionique la clé usb
dans le cerveau pourquoi être plus
technologique passe forcément par être
plus électronique tout numérique en
effet je vous pose une question si on
est tous des robots demain sans limite
qu'est ce qui limitera l'humain qui sera
par exemple l'homme le plus rapide du
monde l'homme ou la femme qui sera le
plus beau le plus intelligent sont peu
tous augmenté notre physique nous
fonctions cognitives et bien face à cela
je peux vous proposer de faire l'éloge
de nos limites biologiques
j'adore attendre mes limites par exemple
quand je fais du sport de la tétine que
je vomis sur la piste ou que j'ai mal à
muscler mais fier de l'avoir fait
j'adore atteindre mes limites quand je
seul face à la nature perdu loin nulle
part et que je sais que je pourrais pas
vivre plus de trois jours dans cet
environnement
j'aime bien atteindre les limites quand
je suis échauffé par ailleurs un câlin
alors que dehors il fait trop froid et
que mon corps n'arrive pas à se
réchauffer tout seul alors je vous
propose de
continuer à avoir des limites ou changer
pour ne plus en avoir
et avouez le sait vraiment ce que l'on
fait par exemple il suffit que le
dernier iphone os x ou ixair sorte et on
a envie de la voir tout de suite mais
après at on vraiment changer
est ce que c'est parce que l'on peut
rendre l'homme et l'humain meilleur
qu'il faut forcément le faire à tout
prix
je pense qu'il est capable qu'on est
capable d'imaginer en transit manie sme
qui ne soit pas celui de la performance
de l'accélération etc mais qui au
contraire plus modestement plus
sereinement et celui qui va nous offrir
un monde plus accessible plus
compréhensible en effet il reste
toujours une limite de logique que
j'aimerais bien augmenter c'est celle
qui est aussi grosse que ça c'est votre
cerveau
elle est aussi grosse que vos demain
vous pouvez faire le test c'est comment
le volume à la glu 5 litres et bien
cette limite là ils nous empêchent
justement de définir le transhumanisme
pas que c'est parce qu'il ya trop de
variables à prendre en compte
d'un seul coup et pareil comprendre la
france l'économie le chômage etc steira
et en même temps il doit être super dur
pour un président de gouverner un pays
mais je pense que comme si on prenait
chaque neurone de votre cerveau pour
créer votre conscience vous pourrez tout
ce soir être le neurone d'une conscience
collective créer des entités plus
performante plus apte à s'attaquer aux
grands problèmes de ce monde mais qui en
même temps serait plus connectés a jerk
à chacun d'entre vous en effet je pense
que c'est la meilleure manière de créer
notre propre transit manie sme c'est en
maîtrisant plus notre monde que nous en
maîtriseront plus ses conséquences alors
c'est bien beau vous allez me dire
peut-être terence et toi qu'est ce que
tu fais pour mieux maîtriser ton monde
parce que c'est ambitieux et bien moi je
travaille sur ça je pense que vous ayez
pas qu'est ce que c'est c'est au petit
c'est transparent
ce sont des neurones sur puce dessus on
fait on est des neurones pour faire en
sorte qu il
soit dans un même micro environnement
que celui de votre cerveau alors cela
permet des choses incroyables
par exemple peut-être un jour se passer
de l'expérimentation animale réduire
drastiquement le coût et le temps que
l'on met à développer un médicament ou
encore et c'est ce qui me plaît ce
moment le plus imaginer les tissus
régénérant de demain et pour en revenir
à mon fils rouges imagine les tissus
régénérant de demain pour moi c'est
choisir la continuité face à la rupture
si on devient robotique alors beaucoup
de personnes pensent que en effet à un
moment nos vies sont radicalement
différentes
je sais pas si vous connaissez l'un des
plus célèbres transhumanistes rikers
island c'est un des directeur de la
recherche à google il dit que en 2029
donc dans dix ans on sera tous capables
de télécharger notre conscience dans des
programmes informatiques et de devenir
ainsi tous des robots est ce que c'est
ce que vous souhaitez normes yeux est ce
que l'on vous a demandé votre avis alors
en effet il ya pas mal de gens comme ça
qui pense c'est la majorité que nos vies
seront radicalement différente à un
moment intense et dur de penser le
contraire à l'aube de la révolution
technologique la plus folle de notre
histoire
une révolution technologique exponentiel
qui va tout changer
accélérez augmenté modifiez transformez
changer la rupture est partout et
d'ailleurs des récentes élections ont
trait ont montré par dont la montée des
extrêmes des extrêmes qui veulent
justement la fin d'un système et un
changement total
mais si finalement il fallait pas
d'abord réfléchir à qu'est ce que l'on
doit garder pour construire justement
nos actions une révolution autour
et si finalement le vrai transhumanisme
c'était celui de la continuité voilà
comment j'imagine exactement le
transhumanisme vie
exactement de la même manière
qu'aujourd'hui pas forcément dans un
futur ultra urbanisées ultra bétonné
ultra robotisés non je pense qu'on
pourra continuer aller courir dehors
sortir avec ses amis aller voir sa
famille
aimer quelqu'un avoir des passions des
loisirs mais ça je pourrais le faire si
j'ai des technologies qui ont du sens
sans peur sans la peur de mourir du
cancer par exemple grâce aux progrès de
la médecine sont la peur de mourir dans
un accident de voiture
grâce aux voitures autonomes sans la
peur d'être sans argent ou même juste
limité par l'argent grâce à
l'automatisation de nos industries de la
production d'énergie ou encore le revenu
universel et pour revenir à mon
ascension de strip du script ada au sri
lanka en 2017
bouda disais que la souffrance vient du
désir alors pourquoi pourquoi avoir
choisi cette ascension où les pèlerins
s'inflige une grue de monter comme
symbole de cette philosophie la
souffrance vient du désir ne faut-il pas
avoir envie d'aller au sommet pour ne
pas ressentir la souffrance de la montée
la souffrance vient du désir je n'ose
pas sûr d'avoir compris l'essence même
de l'éveil de ce besoin de changement
immédiat auquel on pourrait arriver par
le nirvana que pouvait promettre parfois
bouddha en tout cas s'ils existent je ne
peux pas le voir comme un événement
ponctuel dans votre vie mais comme une
perpétuelle continuité en effet je pense
que quand transhumanisme raisonnée mot
d'érable alternatif c'est souhaiter la
continuité de nos pensées de l'humanité
et s'il ya bien quelque chose qui est
peut et doit rester c'est bien lui l'un
en ce sens améliorez l'humain ne
signifie pas forcément le transforme
c'était un pur qui
[Applaudissements]